kirsten joyce is live in studio
explaining more on how to
essentially kirsten bubble safely that's
right brian but first let's be clear
here
when you interact with more people you
do increase your odds of requiring and
spreading covet 19.
staying home and limiting your
face-to-face contact with people is
still the best way to avoid it
but in new zealand and parts of the uk
social bubbles are encouraged
they can be a very effective way of
extending contact beyond the household
if managed properly
because you commit to only hanging out
with certain individuals all right
this might be what many of you are
already doing you probably already have
your
coveted 19 bubble it could be your group
of close friends perhaps extended family
neighbors
even your co-workers but keep in mind
bubbles can also make it a little
difficult to perform contact tracing so
here is how to bubble safely
there we go know about people's health
conditions ask your friends or potential
bubble mates if they have any underlying
health conditions that
could make them more susceptible to
getting covet 19
set some ground rules have a
conversation about what the expectations
are for the group
and know what precautions people have
been taking and one last note feel free
not to bubble even if your best friend
in the world the cdc
says you shouldn't get together with
people who have not been wearing masks
or practicing good hygiene